OK, this is quiz review day.
The quiz coming up on
Wednesday will before this
lecture the quiz will be this
hour one o'clock Wednesday
in Walker, top floor of Walker,
closed book, all normal.
I wrote down what we've
covered in this second part
of the course, and actually
I'm impressed as I write it.
so that's chapter
four on orthogonality
and you're remembering these --
what this is suggesting,
these are those columns are
orthonormal vectors, and then
we call that matrix Q and the --
what's the key -- how do we
state the fact that those v-
those columns are
orthonormal in terms of Q,
it means that Q transpose
Q is the identity.
So that's the matrix
statement of the --
of the property that the
columns are orthonormal,
the dot products are
either one or zero,
and then we computed the
projections onto lines and onto
subspaces, and we used that
to solve problems Ax=b in --
in the least square sense,
when there was no solution,
we found the best solution.
And then finally this
Graham-Schmidt idea,
which takes independent vectors
and lines them up, takes --
subtracts off the
projections of the part
you've already done, so that
the new part is orthogonal
and so it takes a basis
to an orthonormal basis.
And you -- those calculations
involve square roots a lot
because you're making
things unit vectors,
but you should know that step.
OK, for determinants,
the three big --
the big picture is the
properties of the determinant,
one to three d- properties
one, two and three, d-
that define the determinant,
and then four, five,
six through ten
were consequences.
Then the big formula that has
n factorial terms, half of them
have plus signs and half
minus signs, and then
the cofactor formula.
So and which led us to a
formula for the inverse.
And finally, just
so you know what's
covered in from chapter
three, it's section six point
one and two, so that's the
basic idea of eigenvalues
and eigenvectors, the
equation for the eigenvalues,
the mechanical step, this
is really Ax equal lambda
x for all n
eigenvectors at once,
if we have n independent
eigenvectors,
and then using that to
compute powers of a matrix.
So you notice the differential
equations not on this list,
because that's six point three,
that that's for the third quiz.
OK.
Shall I what I usually do for
review is to take an old exam
and just try to pick out
questions that are significant
and write them quickly
on the board, shall I --
shall I proceed that way again?
This -- this exam is really old.
November nineteen --
nineteen eighty-four,
so that was before
the Web existed.
So not only were the
lectures not on the Web,
nobody even had a
Web page, my God.
OK, so can I nevertheless
linear algebra
was still as great as ever.
So may I and that wasn't meant
to be a joke, OK, all right,
so let me just take these
questions as they come.
All right.
OK.
So the first question's
about projections.
It says we're given
the line, the --
the vector a is the
vector two, one, two,
and I want to find the
projection matrix P that
projects onto the
line through a.
So my picture is, well I'm in
three dimensions, of course,
so there's a vector, two --
there's the vector a, two, one,
two, let me draw the
whole line through it,
and I want to project any
vector b onto that line,
and I'm looking for
the projection matrix.
So -- so this -- the projection
matrix is the matrix that I
multiply b by to get here.
And I guess this first
part, this is just part one
a, I'm really asking you the
-- the quick way to answer,
to find P, is just to
remember what the formula is.
And -- and we're in -- we're
projecting onto a line,
so our formula, our -- our
usual formula is AA transpose A
inverse A transpose, but
now A is just a column,
one-column matrix, so it'll be
just a, so I'll just call it
little a, little a transpose,
and this is just a number now,
one by one, so I can put
it in the denominator,
so there's our --
that's really what we
want to remember, and --
and using that two, one,
two, what will I get?
I'm dividing by --
what's the length
squared of that vector?
So what's a transpose a?
Looks like nine, and what's
the matrix, well, I'm --
I'm doing two, one,
two against two,
one, two, so it's one-ninth of
this matrix four, two, four,
two, one, two, four, two, four.
Now the next part asked
about eigenvalues.
So you see we're --
since we're learning,
we know a lot more now, we can
make connections between these
chapters, so what's
the eigenvector,
what are the eigenvalues of P?
I could ask what's
the rank of P. What's
the rank of that matrix?
Uh -- one.
Rank is one.
What's the column space?
If I apply P to all vectors
then I fill up the column space,
it's combinations of the
columns, so what's the column
space?
Well, it's just this line.
The column space is the
line through two, one, two.
And now what's the eigenvalue?
So, or since that
matrix has rank one,
so tell me the eigenvalues
of this matrix.
It's a singular
matrix, so it certainly
has an eigenvalue zero.
Actually, the rank
is only one, so that
means that there
like going to be
t- a two-dimensional null
space, there'll be at least two,
this lambda equals zero
will be repeated twice
because I can find two
independent eigenvectors
with lambda equals zero, and
then of course since it's
got three eigenvalues,
what's the third one?
It's one.
How do I know it's one?
Either from the trace, which is
nine over nine, which is one,
or by remembering what --
what is the eigenvector,
and actually now
it's going to ask
for the eigenvector,
so what's the eigenvector
for that eigenvalue?
What's the eigenvector
It's the -- it's the vector that
doesn't move, eigenvalue one,
so the vector that doesn't move
is a.
This a is the --
is -- is also the eigenvector
with lambda equal one,
because if I apply the
projection matrix to a, I get
a again.
Everybody sees that if I apply
that matrix to a, can I do it
in little letters, if I
apply that matrix to a,
then I have a transpose
a canceling a transpose a
and I get a again.
So sure enough, Pa equals a.
And the eigenvalue is one.
OK.
Good.
now, actually it asks
you further to solve this
difference equation, so
this will be -- this is --
this is solve u(k+1)=Puk,
starting from u0 equal nine,
nine, zero.
And find uk.
So -- so what's up?
Shall we find u1 first of all?
So just to get started.
So what is u1?
It's Pu0 of course.
So if I do the projection of --
of this vector onto the line,
so this is like my vector b now
that I'm projecting
onto the line,
I get a times a transpose
u0 over a transpose a.
Well, one way or another I
just do this multiplication.
but maybe this is the
easiest way to do it.
a transpose, can I
remember what a is on
this board?
Two, one, two, so I'm projecting
onto the line through there.
This is the projection,
it's P times the vector u0,
so what do I have for a
transpose u0 looks like
eighteen, looks
like twenty-seven,
and a transpose a
we figured was nine,
so it's three a, so that this
is the -- this is the x hat,
the -- the multiple of
a, in -- in our formulas,
and of course that's
six, three, six.
So that's u1.
Computed out directly.
That's on the line through a and
it's the closest point to u0,
and it's just Pu0.
You just straightforward
multiplication produces that.
OK.
Now, what's u2?
Well, u2 is Pu1, I agree.
Do I need to compute that again?
No, because once I'm already on
the line through A, uk will be,
I could do the
projection k times,
but it's enough
just to do it once.
It's the same, it's the
same, six, three, six.
So this is a case
where I could and --
and actually on the quiz
if you see one of these,
which could very well be there,
and it could very well be not
a projection matrix, then we
would use all the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
Let's think for a moment,
how do you do those?
M - the point of this small part
of a question was that when P
is a projection matrix, so that
P squared equals P and P cubed
equals P, then -- then we don't
need to get into the mechanics
of all knowing all the other
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
We just can go directly.
But if P was now some other
matrix, can you just --
let's just remember from these
very recent lectures how you
would proceed.
from these very recent lectures
we know that uk we would --
we would expand u0 as a
combination of eigenvectors.
Let me leave -- yeah, as a
combination of eigenvectors,
c1x1, some multiple of
the second eigenvector,
some multiple of the
third eigenvector,
and then A to the ku0
would be c1, so this --
we have to find these numbers
here, that's the work actually.
The work is find
the eigenvalues,
find the eigenvectors and
find the c-s because they all
come into the formula.
We have -- so -- so to do
this, you can see what you have
to compute.
You have to compute
the eigenvalues,
you have to compute
the eigenvectors,
and then to match u0
you compute the c-s,
and then you've got it.
So it's -- it's just that's a
formula that shows what pieces
we need.
And what would actually happen
in the case of this projection
matrix?
If this A is a
projection matrix,
then a couple of
eigenvalues are zero.
That's why we just
throw those away.
The other eigenvalue was a one,
so that we got the same thing
every time, c3x3.
From the first
time, second time,
third, all iterations pro-
left us with this constant,
left us right here
at six, three, six.
But maybe I take --
I'm taking this chance
to remind you of what
to do for other matrices.
OK.
So that's part way through.
The next question in
nineteen eighty-four
is fitting a straight
line to points.
And actually a straight
line through the origin.
A straight line
through the origin.
So can I go to question two?
So this is fitting a straight
line to these points, can I --
I'll just give you the points
at t=1 the y is four, at t=2,
y is five, at t=3, y is eight.
So we've got points one, two,
three, four, five, and eight.
And I'm trying to fit a
straight line through the origin
to these three values.
OK, so my equation that
I'm allowing myself
is just y equal Dt.
So I have only one unknown.
One degree of freedom.
One parameter D.
So I'm expecting to end up
my matrix so my -- my --
when I try to --
when I try to fit a
straight line, that
goes through the origin,
that's because it goes
through the origin, I've
lost the constant c here,
so I have just this should
be a quick calculation.
and I can write down the three
equations that -- that --
that would --
I'd like to solve if the line
went through the points, that's
a good start.
Because that
displays the matrix.
So can I continue that problem?
We would like to solve--
so y is Dt, so I'd like
to solve D times one times
D equals four, two times
D equals five and three
times D equals eight.
That would be perfection.
If I could find such
a D, then the line y
equal Dt would satisfy
all three equations,
would go through all three
points, but it doesn't exist.
So -- so I have to
solve this -- so the --
my matrix is now you can see my
matrix, it just has one column.
Multiplying a scalar D.
And you can see the
right-hand side.
This is my Ax=b.
I don't need three equals signs
now because I've got vectors.
OK.
There's Ax=b and you
take it from there.
You the -- the best x will
be -- will come from --
so what's the --
the key equation?
So this is the A, this is
the Ax hat equal b equation.
Well, Ax=b.
And what's the
equation for x hat?
The best D, so to find
the best D, the best x,
the equation is A
transpose A, the best D,
is A transpose times
the right-hand side.
This is all coming from
projection on a line, our --
our matrix only has one column.
So A transpose A would
be maybe fourteen,
D hat, and A transpose
b I'm getting four, ten,
and twenty-four.
Is that right?
Four, ten and twenty-four.
So thirty-eight.
So that tells me the
best D hat is D hat
is thirty-eight over fourteen.
OK.
Fine.
All right.
so we found the best line.
And now here's a --
here's the next question.
What vector did I just
project onto what line?
See in this section on least
squares here's the key point,
I'm --
I'm asking you to think
of the least squares
problem in two ways.
Two different pictures.
Two different graphs.
One graph is this.
This is a graph in the -- in the
b -- in the tb plane, ty plane.
The -- the -- the line itself.
The other picture I'm
asking you to think of
is like my projection picture.
What -- what projection --
what -- what vector I --
I projecting onto what line or
what subspace when I -- when I
do this?
So the -- my second picture is
a projection picture that --
that sees the whole
thing with vectors.
Here's my vector of course
that I'm projecting.
I'm projecting that vector b
onto the column space of A.
Of if you like -- it's just
a line onto that's the line
it's just a line, of course.
That's what this
calculation is doing.
This is computing the best D,
which is -- this is the x hat.
So -- so seeing it as a
projection means I don't see
the projection in
this figure, right?
In this figure I'm not
projecting those points
onto that line or
anything of the sort.
The projection s-picture for --
for least squares is in the --
in the space where b
lies, the whole vector b,
and the columns of A.
And then the x is
the best combination
that gives the projection.
OK.
So that's a chance
to tell me that.
OK.
I'll go -- OK now
finally in orthogonality
there's the Graham-Schmidt idea.
So that's problem two D here.
It asks me if I have two
vectors, a1 equal one, two,
three, and a2 equal
one, one, one, find
two orthogonal
vectors in that plane.
So those two vectors give
a plane, they give a plane.
Which is of course the --
the column space of the --
of the matrix.
And I'm looking for
an orthogonal basis
for that plane.
So I'm looking for two
orthogonal vectors.
And of course there
are lots of --
I mean, I've got a plane there.
If I get one orthogonal
pair, I can rotate it.
There's not just
one answer here.
But Graham-Schmidt says OK,
start with the first vector,
and let that be --
and keep that one.
And then take the second
one orthogonal to this.
So -- so Graham-Schmidt says
start with this one and then
make a second vector B, can
I call that second vector B,
this is going to be orthogonal
to, so perpendicular to a1.
If I can with my chalk
create the key equation.
This vector B is going
to be this one, one, one,
but that one, one -- one, one,
one is not perpendicular to a1,
so I have to subtract
off its projection,
I have to subtract off the B,
the -- the B trans- ye the B --
the -- the I should say the a1
transpose b over a1 transpose
a1, that multiple of
a1, I've got to remove.
So I just have to
compute what that is,
and I get ano- I get a vector
B that's orthogonal to a1.
It's the -- it's --
it's the original vector
minus its projection.
Oh, so what is --
I mean this to be a2.
So I'm projecting a2
onto the line through a1.
Yeah.
That's the part that I
don't want because that's
in the direction I already
have, so I subtract off
that projection and I
get the part I want,
the orthogonal part.
So that's the
Graham-Schmidt thing
and we can put numbers in.
OK.
one, one, one take away
a1 transpose a2 is six,
a1 transpose a1 is
fourteen,multiplying a1.
And that gives us the
new orthogonal vector B.
Because I only ask for
orthogonal right now,
I don't have to divide
by the length which
will involve a square root.
OK.
Third question.
All right, let me --
I'll move this board up.
third question will probably
be about eigenvalues.
OK.
Three.
This is a four-by-four matrix.
Its eigenvalues are lambda
one, lambda two, lambda three,
lambda four.
Question one.
What's the condition
on the lambdas so
that the matrix is invertible?
OK.
So under what conditions
on the lambdas
will the matrix be invertible?
So that's easy.
Invertible if what's the
condition on the lambdas?
None of them are zero.
A zero eigenvalue would mean
something in the null space
would mean a solution to
Ax=0x, but we're invertible,
so none of them is
zero, the product --
however you want to say, no --
no zero eigenvalues.
Good.
OK, what's the
determinant of A inverse?
The determinant of A inverse?
So where is that
going to come from?
Well, if we knew the
eigenvalues of A inverse,
we could multiply them together
to find the determinant.
And we do know the
eigenvalues of A inverse.
What are they?
They're just one
over lambda one times
one over lambda two, that's
the second eigenvalue,
the third eigenvalue and the
fourth.
So the product of the four
eigenvalues of the inverse
will give us the
determinant of the inverse.
Fine.
OK.
And what's the
trace of A plus I?
So what do we know about trace?
It's the sum down
the diagonal, but we
don't know what our matrix is.
The trace is also the
sum of the eigenvalues,
and we do know the
eigenvalues of A plus I.
So we just add them up.
So what -- what's the first
eigenvalue of A plus I?
When the matrix A has
eigenvalues lambda one, two,
three and four,
then the eigenvalues
if I add the identity, that
moves all the eigenvalues
by one, so I just add
up lambda one plus one,
lambda two plus one, and so on,
lambda three plus one, lambda
four plus one, so it's lambda
one plus lambda two plus lambda
three plus lambda
four plus four.
Right.
That movement by the identity
moved all the eigenvalues
by one, so it moved the
whole trace by four.
So it was the trace
of A plus four more.
OK.
Let's see.
We may be finished this
quiz twenty minutes early.
No.
There's another question.
Oh, God, OK.
How did this class ever do it?
Well, you'll see.
you'll be able to do it.
OK.
this has got to be a
determinant question.
All right.
More determinants and cofactors
and big formula question.
OK.
Let me do that.
So it's about a matrix, a --
a whole family of matrices.
Here's the four-by-four one.
The four-by-four one is, and
-- and all the matrices in this
family are tridiagonal with --
with ones.
Otherwise zeroes.
So that's the pattern, and
we've seen this matrix.
OK.
So the -- it's tridiagonal
with ones on the diagonal,
ones above and ones below, and
you see the general formula An,
so I'll use Dn for
the determinant of An.
OK.
All right.
So I'm going to do a --
the first question is use
cofactors to show that Dn is
something times D(n-1) plus
something times D(n-2).
And find those somethings.
OK.
So this -- the fact that it's
tridiagonal with these constant
diagonals means that there
is such a recurrence formula.
And so the first
question is find it.
Well, what's the
recurrence formula?
OK, how does it go?
So I'll use cofactors
along the first row.
So I take that number
times its cofactor.
So it's one times its cofactor
and what is its cofactor?
D(n-1), right, exactly,
the cofactor is this --
is this guy uses up
row one and column one,
so the cofactor is down
here, so it's one of those.
OK, that's the
first cofactor term.
Now the other cofactor
term is this guy.
Which uses up row
one and column two
and what's surprising
about that?
When you use row one and column
two that brings in a minus.
There'll be a minus
because the --
the cofactor is this
determinant times minus one.
The the one-two cofactor is
that determinant with its sign
changed.
OK.
So I have to look
at that determinant
and I have to
remember in my head
a sign is going to get changed.
OK.
Now how do I do
that determinant?
How do I make that one clear?
I -- the -- the neat way to
do is -- is here I see I --
I'll use cofactors
down the first column.
Because the first column is
all zeroes except for that one,
so this one is now --
and what's its cofactor?
Within this three-by-three its
cofactor will be two-by-two,
and what is it?
It's this, right?
So -- so that part is all gone,
so I'm taking that times its
cofactor, then zero times
whatever its cofactor is,
so it's really just one times
and what's this in the general
n-by-n case?
It's Dn minus two.
But now so is this a plus or
sign or a minus sign, it's --
it's just a one, because there's
a one from there and a one from
there.
And is it a plus or a minus?
It's minus I guess because
there was a minus the first time
and then the second
time it's a plus,
so it's overall it's a minus.
So there's my a and b
were one and minus one.
Those constants.
Th- that's the --
that's the recurrence.
OK.
And oh, then it asks you to then
it asks you to solve this thing
first by writing it as a --
as a system.
So now I'd like to
know the solution.
I -- I better know
how it starts, right?
It starts with D1,
what was D1, that's
just the one-by-one case, so
D1 is one, and what is D2?
Just to get us started and
then this would give us
D3, D4, and forever.
D2 is this two-by-two
that I'm seeing here
and that determinant
is obviously zero.
So those little ones will start
the recurrence and then we take
off.
And then the idea is to
write this recurrence as --
as a Dn, D(n-1) is some
matrix times the one before,
the D(n-1), D(n-2).
What's the matrix?
You see, you remember this step
of taking a single second order
equation and by introducing
a vector unknown to make it
into a --
to a first order system.
OK.
So Dn is one of Dn minus one
minus one, I think that --
that goes in the
first row, right?
From the equation above?
And the second one is
this is the same as this,
so one and zero are fine.
So there's the matrix.
OK.
So now how do I proceed?
We can guess what
this examiner's
got in his little mind.
well, find the eigenvalues.
And actually it tells
us that the sixth power
of these eigenvalues
turns out to be one.
Uh, well, can -- can we get the
equation for the eigenvalues?
Let's do it and let's
get a formula for them.
OK.
So what are the eigenvalues?
I look at the -- the matrix,
this determinant one minus
lambda and zero minus lambda,
and these guys are still there,
I compute that determinant, I
get lambda squared minus lambda
and then plus one.
And I set that to zero.
OK.
So we're not Fibonacci here.
We're -- we're not
seeing Fibonacci numbers.
Because the sign -- we
had a sign change there.
And it's not clear right
away whether these --
whether this -- is it clear?
Is this matrix
stable or unstable?
When we take -- when we go
further and further out?
Are these Ds increasing?
Are they going to zero?
Are they bouncing
around periodically?
the answers have to be here.
I would like to know how big
these lambdas are, right?
And the point is probably
these -- let's -- let's see,
what's lambda?
From the quadratic
formula lambda is one,
I switch the sign of
that, plus or minus
the square root of one minus
4ac, I getting a minus three
there?
Over two.
What's up?
They're complex.
The -- the eigenvalues are one
plus square root of three I
over two and one minus square
root of three I over two.
What's the magnitude of lambda?
That's the key
point for stability.
These are two numbers
in the complex plane.
One plus some -- somewhere
here, and its complex conjugate
there.
I want to know how far from
the origin are those numbers.
What's the magnitude of lambda?
And do you see what it is?
Do you recognize this
-- a number like that?
Take the real part squared
and the imaginary part squared
and add.
What do you get?
So the real part
squared is a quarter.
The imaginary part
squared is three-quarters.
They add to one.
That's a number with --
that's on the unit circle.
That's an e to the i theta.
That's a cos(theta)+isin(theta).
And what's theta?
This -- this is like a complex
number that's worth knowing,
it's not totally
obvious but it's nice.
That's -- I should see that
as cos(theta)+isin(theta),
and the angle that would
do that is sixty degrees,
pi over three.
So that's a -- let me
improve my picture.
So those -- that's e
to the i pi over six --
pi over three.
This is -- this number is e
to the i pi over three and e
to the minus i pi over three.
We'll be doing more
complex numbers briefly
but a little more in
the next two days.
next two lectures.
Anyway, the -- so what's
the deal with stability,
what do the Dn-s do?
Well, look, if -- if I take the
sixth power I'm around at one,
the problem actually
told me this.
The sixth power of those
eigenvalues brings me around to
What does that tell you about
the matrix, by the way? one.
Suppose you know -- this
was a great quiz question,
so I should never have just
said it, but popped out.
Suppose lambda one to the sixth
and lambda two to the sixth are
-- are one, which they are.
What does that tell me
about a m- a matrix?
About my matrix A here.
Well, what -- what matrix
is connected with lambda one
to the sixth and lambda
two to the sixth?
It's got to be the
matrix A to the sixth.
So what is A to the
sixth for that matrix?
It's got eigenvalues
one and one.
Because when I take the
sixth power, actually, ye,
if I take the sixth power b- all
the sixth power of that is one
and the sixth power of that is
one, the sixth power of this
is e to the two pi i, that's
is e to the minus
two pi i, that's one.
So the sixth powers, the -- the
sixth power of that matrix has
eigenvalues one and
one, so what is it?
It's the identity, right.
So if I operate this -- if
I run this thing six times,
I'm back where I was.
The sixth power of that
matrix is the identity.
Good.
OK.
So it'll loop around, it's
-- it doesn't go to zero,
it doesn't blow up, it just
periodically goes around with
period six.
OK.
let's just see if there's a --
all right.
I'll -- let's see.
Could I also look at a --
at a final exam from
nineteen ninety-two.
I think that's yeah, let me
do that on this last board.
It starts -- a lot of the
questions in this exam are
about a family of matrices.
Let me give you the fourth, the
fourth guy in the family is --
has a one, so it's
zeroes on the diagonal,
but these are going one,
two, three and so on.
One, two, three, and so on.
But, for the four-by-four
case I'm stopping at four.
You see the pattern?
It's a family of matrices
which is growing,
and actually the numbers
-- it's symmetric, right,
it's equal to A4 transpose.
And we can ask all sorts of
questions about its null space,
its range, r- its column
space find the projection
matrix onto the column space
of A3, for example, is in here.
So -- so one -- so A3 is zero,
one, zero, one, zero, two,
zero, two, zero.
OK, find the projection
matrix onto the column space.
By the way, is that matrix
singular or invertible?
Singular.
Why do we know it's singular?
I see that column three is
a multiple of column one.
Or we could take
its determinant.
So it's certainly singular.
The projection will be
matrix will be three-by-three
but it will project
onto the column space,
it'll project onto this plane.
The column space of A3, and
I guess I would find it from
the formula AA --
AA transpose A inverse,
I would have to --
I would -- I guess
I would do all this.
There may be a
better way, perhaps
I could think there might
be a slightly quicker way,
but that would come
out pretty fast.
OK.
So that's be the
projection matrix.
Next question.
Find the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of that matrix.
OK.
There's a three-by-three
matrix, oh, yeah,
so what are its eigenvalues
and eigenvectors,
we haven't done any
three-by-threes.
Let's do one.
I want to find, so how
do I find eigenvalues?
I take the determinant
of A3 minus lambda I.
So this is you just have to --
so I'm subtracting lambda from
the diagonal, and I have a
one, one, zero, zero, two,
two there, and I just have
to find that determinant.
OK, since it's three-by-three
I'll just go for it.
This way gives me minus lambda
cubed and a zero and zero.
Then in this direction which
has the minus sign, that's
a zero, four lambdas, I
mean minus four lambdas,
and minus another lambda, so
that's minus five lambdas,
but that direction
goes with a minus sign,
so I think it's
plus five lambda.
That looks like the determinant
of A3 minus lambda I,
so I set it to zero.
So what are the eigenvalues?
Well, lambda equals zero --
lambda factors out of this,
times minus lambda
squared plus four,
so the eigenvalues are
five, thanks, thanks,
zero, square root of five,
and minus square root of five.
And I would never write
down those three eigenvalues
without checking the
trace to tell the truth.
Because -- because we did a
bunch of calculations here
but then I can quickly add up
the eigenvalues to get zero,
add up the trace to get
zero, and feel that I'm --
well, I guess that wouldn't have
caught my error if I'd made it
-- if -- if that had been a
four I wouldn't have noticed,the
determinant isn't anything
greatly useful here, right,
because the determinant
is just zero.
And so I never would
know whether that five
was right or wrong, but
thanks for making it right.
OK.
Ha.
Question two c, whoever
wrote this, probably me,
said this is not difficult.
I don't know why I put that in.
just -- it asks for the
projection matrix onto
the column space of A4.
How could I have thought
that wasn't difficult?
It looks extremely difficult.
what's the projection matrix
onto the column space of A4?
I don't know whether that --
this is not difficult is just
like helpful or -- or insulting.
Uh, what do you think?
The -- what's the
column space of A4 here?
Well, what's our first question
is is the matrix singular
or invertible?
If the answer is invertible,
then what's the column space?
If -- if this matrix A4 is
invertible, so that's my guess,
if this problem's easy it has
to be because this matrix is
probably invertible.
Then its column
space is R^4, good,
the column space
is the whole space,
and the answer to this easy
question is the projection
matrix is the identity, it's the
four-by-four identity matrix.
If this matrix is invertible.
Shall we check invertibility?
How would you find
its determinant?
Can we just like take the
determinant of that matrix?
I could ask you how -- so there
-- there are twenty-four terms,
do we want to write all
twenty-four terms down?
not in the remaining
ten seconds.
Better to use cofactors.
So I go along row
one, I see one --
the only nonzero is this guy,
so I should take that one times
the cofactor.
Now so I'm down to
this determinant.
OK.
So now I'm -- look at this first
column, I see one times this,
there's the cofactor of the
one, so I'm using up row one --
row one and column one of
this three-by-three matrix,
I'm down to this
cofactor, and by the way,
those were both
plus signs, right?
No, they weren't.
That was a minus sign.
That was a --
that was a minus, and then that
was a plus, and then this, so
what's the determinant?
Nine.
Determinant is nine.
Determinant of A4 is nine.
OK.
Where A3, so my guess is I'll
put that on the final this
year, the -- probably the odd-
numbered ones are singular
and the even-numbered
ones are invertible.
And I don't know
what the determinants
are but I'm betting that
they have some nice formula.
OK.
So, recitations this week
will also be quiz review
and then the quiz is
Wednesday at one o'clock.
Thanks.